ZDF heute live euch allen ein herzliches
Willkommen Israel zögert weiter und
verzögert nun wohl auch die Ankündigung
seiner Bodenoffensive die es seit mehr
als über einer Woche gibt die Meldung
kam heute Nachmittag dass es wohl ja
zwei israelische Repräsentanten gibt die
das einem Nachrichtenportal bestätigt
haben dass die Bodenoffensive im
Gazastreifen verschoben werden soll es
hat noch keine offizielle Bestätigung
seitens der israelischen Regierung dazu
gegeben es handelt sich wohl aber laut
Bericht um einen möglichen Deal mit den
Hamas weitere Geiseln freizulassen
währenddessen verstärken die USA ihren
Einfluss auf diesen Konflikt die
US-Regierung redt weiterhin von einer
Bodenoffensive ab schickt aber im
zweiten Schritt Militäroffiziere nach
Israel die beratend helfen sollen bei
den geplanten
Militäroperationen wohl auch im
Interesse von eigenen Interessen welche
das genau sind wie die neue
militärtaktik Israels zu deuten ist die
es da seit dem Wochenende gibt und was
Israel genau zögern lässt im Hinblick
auf die angekündigte Bodenoffensive
darüber wollen wir heute hier reden bei
ZDF heute live mit unseren Experten
unter anderem unserem Korrespondenten in
Israel Michael beverunge mit dem
militäranalysten Hendrik Remmel und auch
mit unserer Reporterin im Studio
Washington Jennifer Girke und dazu gerne
gesehen wie immer hier bei ZDF heute
live eure Kommentare eure Meinungen und
vor allem auch eure Fragen die wir gerne
dann hier in der Sendung auch
beantworten zu versuchen wie immer
schickt ihr uns da gerne über die
kommentarpalten alles weitere was euch
interessiert oder eine Mail an
zdfheute-li@zdf.de und damit schalten
wir zunächst nach Tel Aviv dort steht
unser Reporter Michael bwerunge Michael
einen schönen guten Abend zu dir wir
wollen ganz aktuell starten mit einer
Meldung die es erst vor wenigen
Augenblicken gab ein ja scheinbar ein
eklar der sich da auf diplomatischer
Ebene aktuell abzuzeichnen droht der
israelische UN-Botschafter Gillard erdan
hat vor kurzem auf der Plattform Ex den
Rücktritt von Generalsekretär guterisch
gefordert im gleichen Zuge Außenminister
Ali Cohen hat ein in New York geplantes
Treffen mit dem un-gensekretär
abgesagt erzähl uns was empört Israel da
aktuell so
sehr also ich glaube das empört alle
Menschen Israel quer durch alle
politischen Lager das ist dieser
Relativismus dieses Jahr aber es können
noch die schlimmsten Dinge passieren
aber am Ende ist es immer ein ja aber
und
dieses relative und diese Empörung die
spüre ich auch schon eigentlich den
letzten Jahren immer wieder wenn es um
ähnliche Fälle geht und zwar durch alle
Lager auch die Lager die die Regierung
kritisieren Menschen die sich für eine
zwei statenlösung einsetzen die das
Vorgehen der Armee in dem westjodernland
kritisieren die die Vertreibung der
Palästinenser die Gewalt der Siedler
aber es ist eben ein Unterschied wenn
man sich dieses singuläre Verbrechen
gegen tausende Israelis an einem Tag
anschaut wo Geiseln genommen werden mit
denen immer noch gespielt wird die
Menschen hier hinter mir protestieren
seit Jahre seit Tagen für deren
Freilassung und alle Menschen sagen es
kann doch nicht sein dass diese wirklich
singulären taten immer wieder
relativiert werden ja und doch hat
dieser klar diese Posts die da abgesetzt
werden für ein Ausrufezeichen gesorgt
auf diplomatischer Ebene wir reden da
gleich auch noch mit unserer Reporterin
in Washington drüber wollen jetzt aber
mal einen ganz kurzen Stand der Dinge
uns vor Augen führen was in Israel und
was in Gaza passiert ist und aktuell
passiert das hat Tim Kröger für uns
vorbereitet ein Hamers Video zeigt die
Freilassung der 85-jährigen jochet
lifchitz und der 79 ähgen nur kpper
gestern am späten Abend nah dem
Grenzübergang zwischen Gaza und Ägypten
empfangen werden sie von Helfern des
Roten Kreuzes die Terroristen geben sich
fürsorglich dabei ist es gerade einmal
zweieinhalb Wochen her dass 1400
Menschen in Israel brutal von der Hamas
umgebracht wurden heute vor Reportern
erzählt Jet lifchitz wie sie auf ein
Motorrad gelegt und nach Gaza
verschleppt
wurde auf dem Weg haben sie mich
geschlagen sie haben meineen zwar nicht
gebrochen aber es hat sehr geschmerzt
ich konnte kaum
atmen mit dem Helikopter werden die
beiden Frauen am frühen Morgen in ein
Krankenhaus nach Tel Aviv gebracht sie
sei durch die Hölle gegangen in ein
gigantisches Tunnelsystem einem
Spinnennetz gleich gebracht worden sagt
liefschitz während der Gefangenschaft
aber sei sie gut behandelt worden alle Z
bis D Tage kam ein Arzt um zu
untersuchen wie es uns
gehing Ehemänner der Frauen sind wie
mehr als 200 weitere Geiseln noch immer
in der Hand der Hamas unklar ist wann
eine mögliche israelische Bodenoffensive
im Gazastreifen beginnt und ob diese
unter anderem wegen der Verhandlung über
weitere Geiseln verschoben werden
könnte unsere Kämpfer der israelischen
Armee vor Ort sind bereit und
entschlossen sie trainieren weiter für
den Tag an dem der Befehl kommt derzeit
intensiviert die israelische Armee ih
luftang auf hamasziele in Gaza 400 seien
es in den vergangenen 24 Stunden gewesen
dabei soll es laut Behörden in Gaza
wieder viele Tote gegeben haben ja
soweit ein aktueller Stand der Dinge
Michael auch das eine aktuelle Meldung
neben diesem diplomatischen erlar über
den wir gerade gesprochen haben diese
Meldung über eine mögliche Verschiebung
der Bodenoffensive was hast du da heute
konkret drüber
gehört na ich würde mal sagen so
sensationell ist diese Meldung nicht
denn es ist ja ein Fakt dass diese
Bodenoffensive seit einer Woche jeden
Tag verschoben wird wir berichten
darüber heute hat auch der
Generalstabschef noch mal ganz offiziell
gesagt
äh den Zeitpunkt wann diese
Bodenoffensive kommt äh würden das
Militär und die Regierung in ein
vernehmen darlegen und damit auch klar
gemacht dass sie eben jetzt noch nicht
gefallen ist also ganz klar ist es gibt
die eine äh Verschiebung der
Bodenoffensive wobei immer wieder Beton
wird und ich glaube auch nicht dass sie
in irgendeiner Weise ausgesetzt ist das
heißt sie wird kommen aber natürlich
spielt die geiselfrage spielt eine ganz
zentrale Rolle für den Beginn einer
solchen Bodenoffensive mm und laut
dieser Meldung von heute
spielt da auch ein möglicher neuer Deal
mit den Hamas eine Rolle wie
wahrscheinlich ist es denn dass solch
ein Deal in diesem Stadium des Konflikts
noch zustande
kommt na ja das kann ich von diesem
Standpunkt aus nicht beurteilen aber
klar ist es ist gestern ja auch sehr
deutlich hat es Meldung gegeben dass es
im Gespräch ist weiteren mindestens 50
Geiseln freiubekommen Israelis mit
doppelter Staatsbürgerschaft es geht ja
auch noch immer um Staatsbürger die in
Gaza festsitzen und die Staaten die
natürlich für ihre Staatsbürger
eintreten machen Druck auf Israel dass
es eben erstmal noch weiteren Raum für
Verhandlungen gibt die Kataris
verhandeln seit gestern hat man nichts
mehr über den Fortschritt dieser
Verhandlungen gehört aber sie gehen
natürlich weiter und natürlich gibt es
durchaus gute Chancen weitere Geiseln
jetzt in dieser Phase freiubekommen
allerdings die Kämpfe gehen natürlich
weiter die Bombardements gehen weiter
Israel lnt es ab eine Feuerpause zu
machen um der Hamas eine Kampfpause zu
geben aber es wird mehr Platz für
Verhandlungen geben und insofern ist es
klar dass es solange keine
Bodenoffensive geben wird wie die noch
eine Chance auf Erfolg haben denn wenn
die Bodenoffensive beginnt dann ist die
Chance für Verhandlung erstmal sehr sehr
schlecht eigentlich bis gar nicht und
das Leben der Geiseln ist dann auch in
konkreter Gefahr Stichwort Freilassung
gestern Abend gab es ja dann auch schon
mal wieder eine kleine Erfolgsmeldung
zwei weitere Geiseln von der Hamas
wurden freigelassen wir sehen hier
Bilder aus der letzten Nacht hier kommen
die beiden Geisel in einem Krankenhaus
in Tel Aviv an nach israelischen
Medienberichten handelt es sich um zwei
ältere israelische Frauen 80 und 85
Jahre alt Katar und Ägypten hätten wohl
bei der Freilassung vermittelt die
Ehemänner der beiden Frauen sein aber
weiterhin noch in Hamas Gefangenschaft
heißt das ja Michael geschah das einfach
so man liest ja auch immer von
Forderungen der Hamas z.B nach einer
Waffenruhe über mehrere Stunden das wird
von Israel abgelehnt hatte Israel da was
im Gegenzug für
geleistet
also muss ja erstmal festhandeln
festhalten das ist kein Deal oder kein
handeln wie auf dem Basar das geht auch
nicht um Kidnapper die Lösegeld
verlangen sondern für die Hamas ist das
ein Teil ihres psychokrieges den sie
gegen Israel führen und es geht
eigentlich erstmal nur darum dass diese
Verhandlungen dieses hin und her kommen
noch mehr Geisel frei dass damit Druck
auf Israel ausgeübt werden kann auch
gestern das war die Bilder der Hamas
stellen sich als human her da dass sie
die Geisen gut behandeln das ändert aber
nichts daran dass hier schlicht
Verbrecher am Werk sind die mit Gewalt
Menschen entführt haben mit Gewalt in
ihrer weiteren äh Gewahrsam halten und
das Leben dieser Geisel bedrohen und äh
für die Hamas wie gesagt geht es nicht
um sicherlich auch um detailerfolg aber
die Israelis haben gestern gesagt dass
es keine Zugeständnisse gab jedenfalls
keine Waffenruhe es gab keine Waffenruhe
also insofern ist es glaubhaft dass es
tatsächlich keine Zugeständnisse gab
aber natürlich gibt es einen
Zusammenhang wenn die Israelis z.B
weitere humanitäre Hilfslieferung
zulassen sollen und bisher halten die
israelist das sehr gedrosselt weil das
ist ihr einziges Druckmittel gegen diese
Geiselnehmer und eine Sache ist
besonders heikel wenn es um die
Lieferung von Kraftstoff geht den
brauchen Krankenhäuser natürlich
dringend für ihre Generatoren aber die
Hamas hätte auch gerne welchen und eines
will die israelische Regierung auf jeden
Fall verhindern dass die Hamas in den
Besitz soll ja wenn wir jetzt mal die
letzten Tage zusammenfassen Michael
Stand der Dinge heute was glaubst du
wenn man diese Meldungen liest es
widerspricht sich ja schon so ein
bisschen auch die einindrücke die man da
von der
israelischen Regierung hört wie
widersprüchlich bleibt denn jetzt diese
angekündigte
Bodenoffensive na ja es gibt sehr sehr
widersprüchliche Signale es gibt Signale
dass es eine Vertrauenskrise gibt
zwischen der Armeeführung und
premier Netanyahu dass die Armee sagt
eigentlich müssten wir eine
Bodenoffensive jetzt zügig einleiten es
gibt Meldungen die sagt die Armee will
noch mehr Vorbereitung haben für eine
weitere Offensive ja es gibt Meldung
dass Netanyahu zögert es gibt den Druck
der USA
und auch anderer Staaten es gibt sehr
sehr viele Meldung und die Regierung
sorgt nicht gerade für Klarheit Tatsache
ist wie ich schon gesagt habe seit einer
Woche wird diese Bodenoffensive Tag um
Tag verschoben obwohl immer wieder
betont wird dass die Streitkräfte nun
bereit sein und das ist der Stand
aktuelle Einschätzungen aus Israel von
unserem Korrespondenten Michael
beverunge vielen Dank nach Tel Aviv
schönen
Abend ja und wir wollen jetzt auf die
militärischen Strategien schauen die
sich seit dem Wochenende mutmaßlich
geändert haben von dem israelischen
Militär und das wollen wir ganz
analysieren mit unser unserem
militäranalysten Hendrik Remmel er
verfügt über mehrjährige Erfahrung als
kampftruppenoffizier der Bundeswehr und
ist auch wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter
beim gids der Denkfabrik der Bundeswehr
heute zugeschaltet aus dem Studio
Hamburg und da sehen wir Ihnen schön
guten Abend Herr Remmel schön guten
Abend hallo die Hamas forderte gestern
mehrstündige waffenpausen wir haben es
gerade schon angesprochen Herr Remmel
dazu würden sie im Gegenzug Geiseln
freilassen das wurde von Israel
abgelehnt warum fordert die Hamas
aktuell waffenpausen
mit her Wahrscheinlichkeit weil sie sich
dadurch er hoffen dass sie
m Bewegungsfreiheit in gaserstreifen
zurückerlangen denn eine Waffenpause
bedeutet es gibt keine Luftschläge mehr
es gibt keine artillerieschläge mehr das
heißt die sogenannte
stallfeuerkomponente im gaserstreifen
würde zumindest für ein paar Tage
ausgesetzt werden das heißt die Hamas
kann sich in dieser Phase wieder frei
bewegen wir nennen das Konsolidierung
Militär das heißt gegebenenfalls
aufgegebene Stellung zurückgewinnen
und gegebenenfalls auch ihre
Verteidigungsstellung die zerstört
worden sind
soweit es geht wieder zu reparieren
wieder zu befestigen
auf der anderen Seite muss Israel
einen sehr harten abwegungsprozess
durchführen da sind wir auf der
strategischen Ebene ähm in einem
durchaus starken Dilemma ähm auf der
einen Seite aus rein militärischen
Gesichtspunkten kann Israel sich es kaum
erlauben diese m Feuerpause einzugehen
Israel würde dadurch die Initiative
verlieren ähm und der Hamas einen
gewissen Vorteil verschaffen um sich
wieder zu reorganisieren auf der anderen
Seite wächst natürlich der
internationale Druck
von Tag zu Tag von jedem zivilen Opfer
was welche dieser welch dieser Krieg
fordert und in diesem abwegungsprozess
scheint sich Israel und vor allem die
israelische Regierung zum geg
gegenwertigen Zeitpunkt zu befinden nun
gibt's Berichte vom Wochenende dass
Israel die Militärstrategie die eigene
wohl geändert hat da ist die Rede von
Infanterie und Panzer die auf
sondierungseinsätze geschickt wurden in
den Gazastreifen es gibt verstärkte
Luftangriffe auf Gebiete in denen nach
israelischer Darstellung islamistische
Kämpfer ihren Hinterhalt haben die man
da aus der Luft angreift wie ist das
militärisch einzuordnen ist das jetzt
schon die Vorstufe einer möglichen
Bodenoffensive also also zum einen halte
ich es für unrealistisch dass Israel
seine Militärstrategie verändert hat
denn die strategischen Ziele die sich
Israel gesetzt hat mit einer
Bodenoffensive in den Gasastreifen
nämlich zum einen die Wiederherstellung
der inneren Sicherheit
also ein strategisches Ziel nach innen
und zum anderen die Wiederherstellung
einer glaubhaften abschreckungslogik in
dieser
Region sind aus meiner Sicht
unverändert zum zweiten muss man
verstehen dass ein eine Militäroperation
der Beginn einer vermeintlichen
Bodenoffensive weder groß verkündet wird
noch werden wir zwangsläufig klare
Anzeichen dafür sehen die Übergänge in
solchen Operationen die Phasen sind in
der Regel fließend richtig ist dass wir
eine verstärkte Anzahl an Luftschlägen
in den letzten Tagen beobachten können
das spricht dafür dass die israelischen
Streitkräfte ihre Aufklärung die
sogenannte Generierung eines lagebildes
verbessert haben das heiß sie haben mehr
Ziele die sie beschießen können also tun
sie dies auch die sogenannten
konsolidierungsangriffe können
zwei militärische Faktoren zum zum Zweck
haben die erste ist eine sogenannte
gefechtsaufklärung das heißt eine
bodengestützte Aufklärung um mögliche
Stellung der hamaskämpfer aufzuklären
und sie dann entweder direkt mit den
bodenkräften zu bekämpfen oder dann eine
Verbindung mit steifeuer oder
Luftschlägen zu bekämpfen und die andere
Möglichkeit ist
dass spezialkräft in den letzten Tagen
versucht haben Geiseln zu befreien auch
bodenestützt das sind die beiden
Optionen
grundsätzlich ist das eine Voraussetzung
schaffende Aktivität um eine
vollumfängliche konventionelle
Bodenoffensive einzuluten unser
Zuschauer Sven odental schreibt uns auf
Facebook auf eine Bodenoffensive dürfte
die hamassia jetzt mittlerweile
eingestellt sein die Offensive ist ja
jetzt seit über einer Woche angekündigt
müsste man nicht Strategien entwickeln
auf die die hammas nicht vorbereitet ist
und äh die sie nicht verhindern
kann ja das ist eine sehr gute Frage ist
eine der Grundfragen in der
Militärstrategie wie schaffe ich es
einen sogenannten Überraschungseffekt zu
erzielen das wird in der heutigen Zeit
in der gefechtsfelder Nahe zuu Gläsern
sind also sowohl im cyberraum als auch
durch
drohenaufklärung im Grunde genommen es
kaum mehr möglich ist seine eigene
militärische Absicht glaubhaft zu
verschleiern ungeheuer
komplex ich bin fest davon über zeugt
dass die Hamas nicht erst nach dem
Überfall damit begonnen haben die
Verteidigung im gaserstreifen
vorzubereiten die Hamas hatte 9 Jahre
Zeit diese Verteidigung vorzubereiten
das wird sie getan haben sie wird
Tunnelsysteme sowohl für Defensive als
auch für offensive Aktivitäten nutzen
sie wird Hinterhalte vorbereitet haben
sie wird Sprengfallen vorbereitet haben
sie wird alles dafür getan haben um in
eine asymmetrische Kriegsführung
überzugehen das heißt die technischen
Vorteile der israelischen Streitkräfte
zu minimieren und sie auf das Niveau auf
das technologische Niveau
herunterzubringen auf dem die Hamas
erfolgreich sein kannm ich will zuletzt
mit ihn Herr Remmel noch auf die USA
blicken und auf die Frage warum sich die
USA so stark allgemein in diesen
Konflikt einmischt ich rekapituliere
noch mal die haben jetzt mittlerweile
zwei Flugzeugträger in Richtung Israel
geschickt und laut Angaben des
nationalen Sicherheitsrates auch
mittlerweile Militärberater die für
künftige Strategien da Israel beratend
zur Seite stehen wollen und das
interessiert auch unsere m Zuschauer z.B
Eiler schreibt uns auf Youtube wie kann
die Bodenoffensive dahingehend verstal
gestaltet werden versucht die USA die
Offensive in ihrer Art zu beeinflussen
was glauben
Sie sie wird sie versuchen zu
beeinflussen zu Gunsten Israels Israel
und die USA sind enge
sicherheitsstrategische Verbündete in
der Region
vor allem im Nahen Osten ist Israel ein
stabiler sicherheitsstrategischer
Partner für die USA
die Trägergruppen sind eine Projektion
der macht auch ein glasklares Signal an
die hisbolla und an den Iran nicht in
diesen Konflikt einzugreifen eine
Trägergruppe lag schon vorher im
Mittelmeer die andere liegt derzeit im
Persischen Golf und wir haben auch noch
Schiffe Kampfschiffe im Roten Meer die
bereits marschlug Körper und lang
streckenraketen der hutirebellen aus dem
Jemen die Richtung Israel geflogen sind
abgeschossen haben das Signal an die
strategischen Akteure in der Region die
gegebenenfalls zum Verbündeten oder
bereits schon zum Verbündeten gemacht
worden sind der Hamas ist sehr klar
die USA werden eine Eskalation des
Konfliktes in der Region versuchen mit
allen Mitteln zu verhindern weil es
nicht in ihrem strategischen Interesse
ist dass neben dem Angriffskrieg
Russlands in der Ukraine noch ein
zweiter regionaler Konflikt ausbricht
der ihrem ursprünglichen strategischen
Ziel ihrer strategischen Ausrichtung
seit 2015 widerspricht nämlich sich auf
eine geostrategische
Rivalität gegen China mit China im
inuazifik vorzubereiten sagt der
militäranalistst Hendrik Remmel Herr
Remmel danke für das Gespräch heute
abend Grüße nach Hamburg sehr gerne ja
die Rolle der USA erscheint ziemlich
widersprüchlich wenn wir uns die letzten
Tage anschauen zum einen schickt man
Offiziere die nach Israel bei den
Vorbereitungen einer Bodenoffensive
helfen sollen andererseits warnt man
vor einer Bodenoffensive und redt Israel
zur Zurückhaltung die starke Einmischung
in den Konflikt zeichnen vor allem auch
eigene Interessen aus der USA ein kurzer
Überblick dazu von elisabel
schevafera die Bodenoffensive in Gaza
ist wohl verschoben offenbar wollen die
USA Zeit gewinnen um die Lieferung
humanitärer Hilfe in den Gazastreifen
voranzubringen und es gibt einen
weiteren Grund aus Sicht Washingtons im
Fall einer völligen Eskalation des gaz
Konflikts hat hat die US-Regierung laut
einem Medienbericht einen Plan für die
Evakuierung aus dem Nahen Osten
ausgearbeitet demnach geht es um rund
600.000 Menschen mit US
Staatsbürgerschaft in Israel sowie
weitere 10000 im Libanon Washington
wolle die Zeit zudem nutzen um
amerikanische Einrichtungen in der
Region für den Fall von
Vergeltungsschlägen zu
sichern ja über die Rolle der USA möchte
ich jetzt sprechen mit unserer ZDF
Reporterin Jennifer Girke die im ZDF
Studio Washington zugeschaltet ist einen
schönen guten Abend zu dir
Jennifer das
uspräidialamt das Verteidigungs und
Außenministerium das haben haben erst
gestern Israel von einer Bodenoffensive
abgeraten das steht die Frage im Raum
warum mischt man sich da aktuell so
stark ein und welche eigenen Interessen
verfolgen die USA
scheinbar ja die USA mischen sich nicht
nur ein die USA sind natürlich auch
direkt betroffen davon schli sich sind
auch unter den von der Hamas in Geisel
genommenen Menschen US-amerikanische
Staatsbürger und StaatsbürgerInnen zudem
sind Israel und USA enge Partner und
eine Stabilisierung des Nahost des
nahostens und der der nahostregion war
für US-Präsident Biden immer schon eine
wichtige Aufgabe
einen ein wichtiges geopolitisches und
und auch außenpolitisches Ziel
aber das heißt beiden kann sich
eigentlich nicht nicht einmischen
aufgrund von seiner Verantwortung und
Rolle ähm gegenüber seiner eigenen
Bevölkerung aber auch in der
nahostregion gleichzeitig aber auch ein
bisschen vorsichtig sein mit dem Begriff
einmischen bzw wie weit geht diese
Einmischung bisher wenn man US-Präsident
Biden oder auch sein
Verteidigungsminister Austen oder
Plinken den Außenminister gehört hat
hieß es das nicht dass man vorschreibt
was man zu tun hat das heißt die USA
haben Israel eine Stange an Hilfe
gegeben unterstützen Sie auch
militärisch aber sie geben nicht vor was
sie wann wo mit dieser militärischen
Unterstützung machen dabei betonen sie
eben auch immer wieder wir stehen an
ihrer Seite wir stehen an der Seite
Israels das ist das Mantra was man seit
Beginn dieses dieses Konfliktes dieses
dieser Eskalation in nost immer wieder
gesagt hat und diese ja ich sag mal
Freiheit gegenüber gegenüber Israel also
dass man es ihnen dass man ihn es Ihnen
frei lässt wie sie mit der Hilfe umgehen
das hat auch gestern noch mal John Kirby
der kommunikationsdirektor des Nation
Sicherheitsrates bestätigt im Weißen
Haus zum einen also ist die USA
natürlich direkt betroffen zum anderen
ist beiden einfach jemand der sehr stark
auch klar machen will in einem Kampf der
Systeme setzt er sich ganz klar für die
Demokratie ein und ist er der Vertreter
und der verföchter der Demokratie und
das hat man auch immer wieder in seinen
letzten Botschaften gehört so auch in
der Rede an die Nation vor einigen Tagen
ich zitiere einmal ganz kurz da sagte er
die Geschichte lehrt uns wenn Terrorist
und Diktatoren keinen Preis für ihren
Terror und Aggression Zahlen richten Sie
noch mehr Chaos Tod und Zerstörung an
das heißt dieser dieser Konflikt
beinhaltet für die USA natürlich ganz
viele Interessen und Anstrengungen da
könnte ich mir vorstellen spielt auch
Angst eine Rolle die man da hinter den
Kulissen aktuell hat weil man liest
Meldungen dass es das befürchtet wird
dass die Anschläge auf US-Einrichtungen
zunehmen sollte diese Bodenoffensive
dann starten der Konflikt eskalieren
oder auch die Washington Post schreibt
über ähm Pläne einer massenevakuierung
die da im Hintergrund von der
US-Regierung vorbereitet werden es geht
da wohl um über 600.000 US Staatsbürger
in Israel die dann schnellstmöglich
evakuiert werden sollen also wie gedenkt
man denn da von US-Seite einzugreifen
sollte der Konflikt
eskalieren genau du hast es gerade schon
angesprochen es bezieht sich momentan
alles auf einen Bericht
auf
ja einen Bericht der Washington Post die
hat
mit hohen offiziellen gesprochen
allerdings anonym man weiß nicht
wirklich woher diese Information kommen
oder von wem sie konkret kommen gerade
eben vor einen vor wenigen Minuten gab
es ein ein das White House Briefing im
Weißen Haus da hat wieder John Kirby der
Sicherheitsberater gesprochen der hat
das nicht bestätigt dass es jetzt solche
konkreten Vorhaben schon geben wird aber
er hat gesagt es wäre absolut
unverantwortlich wenn es nicht dafür
Pläne gibt wenn man sich nicht darüber
Gedanken machen würde okay wie kann wie
wie wie können wie müssen wir das
das amerikanische Volk also die
amerikanischen Staatsbürger in Israel
und im Libanon schützen wenn es dann
wirklich zu einer Ausweitung dieses
Konfliktes kommt das heißt
bottomline ist es ganz klar ein worstcee
Szenario das betont auch dieser Bericht
immer wieder aber es ist ebenso wichtig
dass man sich eben auf so ein Worstcase
Szenario vorbereitet denn bei aller
diplomatischen Bemühungen blickt man
natürlich auch mit Sorge auf die ja
Anspannungen und auf die auf die
Proteste im in der arabischen Welt und
auch ja merkt man natürlich dass das
dort gewisse Fronten sich gegenüber
stehen und ja man hat natürlich auch
Angst dass US- Truppen Ziel werden
könnten aber nichtsdestotrotz ich sag
noch mal Präsident Biden hat dort einige
an eigenen Staatsbürgern im Gaza um die
er sich natürlich auch sorgt und kümmert
und deren Freilassung eines seiner
absoluten Prioritäten ist was würde das
konkret bedeuten wenn es zu so einer
Massen evaku ung kommen würde auch da
wie gesagt das ist alles nur bezogen auf
diesen einen Bericht aber natürlich
beschäftigt man sich laut diesem Bericht
der der Washington Post nun um
entsprechende Logistik also wie könnte
diese Logistik überhaupt aussehen und in
diesem Bericht sagt es aber auch dass je
nach Umfang einer solchen Evakuierung
könnte diese Aktion schwieriger sein als
alle anderen bishergigen Operationen der
jüngeren Vergangenheit man könnte dabei
auch Flugzeuge der Luftwaffe oder auch
Kriegsschiffe der Navy einsetzen die ja
in dem Zuge der militärischen Aufrüstung
und und und Hilfe an Israel bereits in
dieser Region entsandt worden sind mhm
diese Einmischung der USA in diesem
Konflikt interessiert unsere Zuschauer
und User aktuell sehr ihr könnt uns
weiterhin eure Fragen übrigens schicken
das habt ihr auch schon fleißig getan
Senn odental Jennifer fragt z.B gerade
geht es den USA nicht eher darum die
geopolitische Vormachtstellung in
einzelnen Regionen zu stabilisieren und
könnte da ein ausgeweiteter
nchostkonflik gt nicht nachteilig am
Ende für die USA
sein die USA Streben sicherlich keine
Ausweitung eines naoskonfliktes an das
ist auch gerade der Grund warum wir
sehen dass ich diese Bodenoffensive in
Israel natürlich hinzögert hinauszögert
und beiden hat er sicherlich einen
Anteil dran er er ist ein ein ein
Diplomat der hält an diplomatischen
Verhandlungen fest er sagt natürlich ich
muss mich vor allenen auch darum kümmern
dass meine eigenen Leute rauskommen aber
dass es eben keinen Flächenbrand in
dieser Region kommt denn eine instabile
nahostregion wie der User auch ganz
richtig sagt hilft letztendlich den den
den den westlichen Alliierten einen
einem US-Präsident beiden der ja dafür
steht Stabilität dort hineinzubringen
der dafür steht demokratische Systeme zu
stärken das hilft ihm sicherlich
überhaupt nicht also ich würde sagen m
Jain es ist sicherlich ein ein ein
Interesse von Ihnen diese geopolitische
Stabilität
nicht aufzugeben bzw an an der
geopolitischen Stabilität oder der die
Errichtung davon weiter dran
festzuhalten und auch sicherlich hat er
das Interesse daran an seine eigenen
Leute zu denken und US-amerikanische
Geiseln dort aus der aus der Haft zu
befreien mhm Jennifer lass uns zuletzt
wie angekündigt noch mal auf den
aktuellen eklar schauen den es da vor ja
einer knappen Stunde ungefähr im
Unrat gab ein
auf der Plattform Ex vom israelischen
UN-Botschafter hat da ein Ausrufezeichen
gesetzt der hat den Rücktritt von
Generalsekretär guterisch gefordert
gleichzeitig hat der israelische
Außenminister Cohen ein in New York
geplantes Treffen abgesagt diese
Meldungen sind jetzt noch nicht so alt
gab es da schon erste Reaktionen aus
Washington ja wie man das einschätzen
kann du hattest gerade kurz skizziert
der UN Generalsekretär guterisch wurde
sehr sehr deutlich mit seinen Worten im
sicher im Sicherheitsrat heute er sagte
er sei besorgt über eindeutige
Verletzungen des internationalen
humanitären rechts und wie man das
aufgegriffen hat auf Seiten des
israelischen botschafts ist eben man man
ja sie liest das als ein Verständnis für
eine Kampagne des Massenmordes an Kinder
Frauen und älteren Menschen und das
zeigt einfach auch wieder wie ja wie
schwer es ist diesen Spagat zu machen
den wir ähm durch Weg diese
diplomatischen Bemühungen gerade sehen
auf der einen Seite natürlich die ähm ja
e Solidarität mit Israel hohe hilfs
Hilfslieferungen auch an sie ein ein
einfach schon aus der aus der Geschichte
her herausgeborenes enges Verhältnis
dazu wofür auch die beiden
Administration natürlich steht und auf
der anderen Seite aber eben auch
wirklich eine eine Zivilbevölkerung im
Gasastreifen die man nicht außer Acht
lassen darf um die man sich natürlich
auch kümmern muss und eben auch wenn wir
jetzt auf diese diplomatische
Höhe gehen auf diese ja geopolitische
haben wir dort wichtige arabische Player
in dem Raum die man bei all der
Solidarität mit Israel natürlich nicht
außer Acht lassen darf man hat so ging
diese Szene dann ein bisschen weiter als
nach guterisch der israelische Vertreter
gesprochen hat haben einige arabische
also Vertreter einige arabischer Länder
den Raum verlassen andere wiederum sind
geblieben die die wir jetzt schon in
eher der Vermittlerrolle gesehen haben
wie z.B Jordanien aber es sind eben auch
welche aufgestanden und gegangen und das
ist ja ein ganz klares
Ja sichtbares Zeichen
dass dass man sich dort dass man sich
dort abgrenzt dass man nicht immer on
speaking terms ist und dass dort einfach
auch noch viel
ja viel weitere diplomatische Bemühungen
notwendig sein werden um diesen spargard
immer wieder zu schaffen mhm wir haben
noch eine Frage von Oliver krögel auf
Youtube reinbekommen Jennifer man muss
dazu sagen noch mal vorab die USA haben
ja in dem Sinne schon eingegriffen als
dass sie zwei Flugzeugträger kurz nach
den Terrorattacken in Richtung Israel
geschickt hatten erstmal zur
abschreckenden Wirkung Oliver krögel
fragt dazu stellen diese flugze stellt
die USA ihre Flugzeugträger nur für den
Fall bereit wenn der Iran in den
Konflikt eingreift oder äh ist da auch
noch eine andere Bedeutung
dahinter ja umfassende Informationen
dazu liegen mir nicht vor aber man hat
immer wieder ähm gesagt es ist nicht das
ähm das ist nicht das erste Ziel dass
US-amerikanische Truppen direkt und
aktiv in diesen in diesen Konflikt ein
Eingreifen wir haben gerade eben über
diese mögliche ähm äh Pläne der
massenevakuierung gesprochen auch da kam
ja zur Sprache ähm auch für solche
Zwecke könnte man natürlich ähm ähm die
die Army oder die Navy die ähm die
Kriegsschiffe dortfür einsetzen das
heißt da ist ziemlich viel Know-how
stationiert was an unterschiedlichen
Stellen eingesetzt werden kann es gibt
eine Spezialeinheit das hat Austin auch
auch gesagt der der
Verteidigungsminister äh die eben dem
israelischen der israelischen Armee zur
Seite steht ähm man hat genau diese
Möglichkeiten dort für für den Fall der
Fälle ob das ein Evakuierung Fall ist
oder ein anderer Fall das das bleibt
noch offen aktuelle Einschätzungen live
aus Washington von ZDF Reporterin
Jennifer Girke Jennifer vielen
Dank danke euch ja und in diesem Fall
dann auch Danke an euch wieder fürs
Interesse fürs fleißige kommentieren und
all eure Fragen das war ZDF heute live
für heute wir sagen tschüss und bis
bald
ه